we've seen one of the most brutal fight
scenes in Game of Thrones so far between
the red Viper and the mountain but where
does it rank in the most epic faceoff on
the show if this is your first time here
I do tons of exclusive interviews with
the gamer turns Carlson regular t-shirt
giveaways on my weekly Game of Thrones
reviews - so if you haven't already
subscribe below ok let's take a look at
my countdown of the top 10 best game of
Thrones face offs self sword ron LED
heavily armored Knights er bodice and
Mary dance around the eerie throne room
when he fought during Tyrians trial by
combat
after tiring out serve Ardis with his
ducking and diving bran went in for the
kill bundling the Knights body out the
moon door all of which led to a classic
exchange between crazy Lysa Arryn and
broth you don't fight with honor
she said no eaded said bran looking down
the moon ghoul points for this faceoff a
great character bran
engages an edge of deceit combat was
great humor in this a fantastic moondoor
death but - points for dirty tactics
remember Brienne's journey to take Jaime
Lannister to King's Landing and exchange
him for Catelyn Stark's daughters well
Jamie saw Brienne killed three men
single-handed during that time yet he
still thought he'd be able to beat
Brienne as they crossed a bridge despite
the fact his hands were tied and he
wasn't in peak practice or condition
after being held prisoner for so long
nevertheless Jamie proved he still had
some moves when he grabbed one of priam
swords and started trading blows and
insults with his captor of course
Brienne did get the better of him but
only just in time to be taken prisoner
herself along with Jaime by house Bolton
man Locke as Jaime waved goodbye to his
right hand later I bet he was wishing he
hadn't wasted valuable time battling
Brienne on that bridge points for this
faceoff Brienne beats the cocky
Kingslayer points against for Jaime not
being full Fitness the city of marine
didn't exactly throw Danny in her band
of merry men a welcome party when they
arrived in season 4 instead they sent
out their champion to do battle with
Danny's best man grey worm Jorah and bar
and all step forward but Jani rejected
them as too valuable to her so Dario
took on this particular pissing contest
with his usual display of [ __ ] Shauna's
refusing a horse despite the fact his
merry news opponent was bearing down on
here on horseback with a lance
Dario winked at Danny kissed his knife
and threw it at his opponent's horse
which reared up sending its rider to the
ground in a cloud of dust
leaving Dario to slay him with his
sickle sword as he tried to get her
points for this faceoff for Dario's
cheeky bravura the humor of it and the
manner of the Mariners cowards death Ned
Stark had stepped down as a king pound
and was getting ready to return to
Winterfell
when Littlefinger took him to his
brothel to follow another clue in the
death of former hand Jon Arryn as Ned
left the brothel who should be there to
greet him but Jaime Lannister who wasn't
exactly in the best mood following his
brother taryn's arrest q of bloody fight
which saw the slaughter of all Ned's men
including Jory Cassell who Jaime killed
with a dagger right through the eye then
Jaime and Ned faced off with some nifty
sword work before their fight was ended
prematurely by a Lannister man who
stabbed Ned in the knee still I guess
Ned had a bit more to worry about than a
limp before the end of season 1 points
for this faceoff two amazing characters
faced off with some brilliant swordplay
and a gruesome death during Brienne's
journey with Jaime she came across three
dead women hanging from a tree who'd
been killed by stark men for sleeping
with Lannisters Brienne was about to cut
them down and bury them when three stark
soldiers appeared and started
questioning her about her prisoner when
one of the men recognized Jaime Brienne
took swift action killing two of them in
six seconds flat while giving the third
man a more lingering exit so two quick
deaths and a slow one the same way those
men treated the woman hanging from the
tree points for this faceoff a great
character meeting out justice with super
speedy strength
[ __ ] legend Karl Tanner almost proved
over in motels Maxim that long swords
are a bad option in close quarters
during his fight with John snow inside
Craster's keep
not only did John have to dodge cars to
daggers but he also had to put up with
his constant trash talk about fighting
with honor while Karl fought dirty
spitting in John's I am tripping him up
he was only thanks to one of Craster's
women stabbing Karl in the back that
John was able to get back on his feet
and run his sword through the back of
Karl's head right out of his mouth a
fitting end for the man who only one
episode before had been drinking wine
from the skull of Lord Commander Mormont
oh and if you're thinking the way John
killed Karl looks familiar
well done for remembering how Tyrians
former spy Podrick saved his master of
Blackwater points for this faceoff for
killing off the super villain Karl but
minus points because Jon Snow needed
help to win after a pregnant Daenerys
stopped the Dothraki from raping the
women of a village that conquered
druggers rider Magog complained to his
car
but when Drago sided with Danny rather
than back down
mago drew his sword on Drago saying a
Karl who takes orders from a foreign
[ __ ] is no call now Drago wasn't the
kind of man to take an insult like that
lying down instead he deliberately
pushed himself against Margot's all rock
a kind of sized sword before tossing his
own daggers aside sharing his contempt
of may go after some nifty footwork and
ducking and diving an unarmed Drago used
Magos own sort lit his throat and then
ripped out his tongue I love the way
that Drago just tossed Magos Cheng aside
then went back to sitting down like it
was all nothing of course it didn't all
end well for Trago though as that wound
you got from Margot's sword started to
fester and well we all know what
happened after that points for this
faceoff for an amazing death and badass
Drago backing up Danny - points for his
hubris leading to Drago's own demise
Kingsguard Meryn Trant and a gaggle of
Lannister men tried to take aiya stock
during high water dancing lesson with
Syrio Forel first sword of Braavos with
Ned banged up for treason things were
not looking good for the youngest stark
daughter but Serio bravely stood between
the wolf cub and the Lions yes
everyone's favorite master swordsman
Serio took on and beat not one not two
but five steel sword wielding Lannister
men with nothing more than a wooden
practice sword with only Meryn Trant
left to face Syrio insisted aiya leave
though he wouldn't flee himself as the
first sword of Braavos does not run
points for this faceoff for sword skills
bravery and pithy sayings yes Syrio
Forel has it all although Serio said not
today to the god of death i believe he
is dead however we don't see his death
on screen but what do you think about
syria is he a goner or is he still with
us oh and you can check out my into you
with mill TAS who plays Serio here
season three saw the Hound go
head-to-head with beric Dondarrion
leader the Brotherhood without banners
accused by aya of murdering her friend
Micah the butcher's boy which Sandor did
on Joffrey the orders in season 1 the
Hound was sentenced to trial by combat
but this wasn't just any regular old
sword fight
beric Dondarrion used magic and his own
blood to set fire to his sword and we
all know the Hound isn't exactly fond of
flames after his brother Gregor shipped
him into the fire as a child for playing
with his toys cue a blazing battle that
Barret looked set to win when the hounds
wooden shield caught fire yet the Hound
overpowered his phone slicing right
through Barret scorching sword as well
as his armor and his shoulder and as if
that wasn't enough the Lord of Lights
Priest
Saurus of mir brought Barracks back to
life the whole scene was filled with
actual flaming swords inside belfast
paint hall studios in 50 degrees celsius
heat and richard dormer who plays
barrack lost 10 pounds in weight when
filming it and if you want to hear more
from Maisie Williams he plays aya and
richard dormer about filming that scene
then click here to watch my interviews
with
points for this face-off barek literally
fought with fire and came back to life
and number one yes it couldn't be
anything else but the red Viper versus
the mountain
yes oberyn martell finally got his
chance to go head-to-head with gregor
clegane the man who raped and murdered
his sister Elia Martell and her children
just like in bronze battle with serve
Ardis Oberyn chose light armor and no
helmet over Gregor's heavier gear hell
they even knocked back a glass of wine
ahead of the fight then he uttered the
worst words a TV or movie character can
ever say if they actually want to live
today's not the day I die and on top of
that he promised to never leave his
lover ilaria fans alone in this world
there was lots of fancy footwork and
skilled sphere play from Oberyn a heart
in mouth moment when the mountain broke
the red Vipers spear and eventually the
mountain was felled but just when you
hoped your favorite snake might slither
away with his life
bronze words to Tyrion about why he
wouldn't fight the mountain came
flooding back to us maybe I could take
him dance around and saw these Tanner
backing at me he drops his sword getting
off his feet somehow but one misstep and
I'm dead and so it was with Oberyn whose
obsession with hearing Gregor confessed
people who died ended with the red Viper
squished just like the beetles Tyrians
cousin Austin used to crush incessantly
points for this face-off well our
favorite David almost beat this beast of
a Goliath in a dancing display of
dexterity points against however for
getting squeezed like a lemon so what
are your top face offs in Game of
Thrones other ones I liked but it didn't
quite make my top 10 list include
Brienne versus Laura which is a great
fight and Jon Snow vs. qhorin Halfhand
let me know in the comments below if
there's any other faceoff you really
liked don't forget to subscribe so you
don't miss out on more top 10s coming up
as well as episode reviews and exclusive
cast interviews I remember if you're not
watching Jan G on G ot
you know nothing